PITTSBURGH AND ALEX HAD MADE ONJ
KASE AND NOW IT IS BUNTING, THIS
TIME STOPPED BY HERE
TONIGHT. THE FORMER MAPLE LEAFS
HEAD COACH, GAVE HIM HIS FIRST
JOB.B.
KEN: JUST OFFSIDE AS BERTUZZI
HAD NOT CLEARED.
MICKEY: OH, ENGVALL NOW MANY AHD
FOR JASON SPEZZAA CENTER, ENGVAT
OF PRETTY
KICKED BACK NOW TO CENTER AND
HERE NOW, DECIDED,
HEY, I WANT TO GO AND THEN HE
NOW HOLL.
THIS IS T.J. BRODIE. UP
HERE BUT LET'S SEE.
ONCE AGAIN, A NOTHING PLAY. JUSE
BIT.
AND NOW BOTH GET A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT LOOOO AGAINST DETROITR
THIS SEASON BUT COULD NOT GET IT
IT?
SANDIN?
BUNTING, LIVING UP TO HIS NAME,
RIGHT THERE. THE BID FOR THE HA.
TORONTO WITH WIDE AND NOW WE'VE
GOT A TIE GAME AND, OH, BOY, O O
OVERTIME, COULD YOU IMAGINE,
THREE-ON-THREE, MATTHEWS,
MARNER, THE
GREYHOUNDS. IT AND THEN ICE
THE PUCK, THAT IS FOR C NOW.S T,
FIRST, EMPTY NET AGAIN